we made this movie in a very old-school
classic way we've built huge huge sets
and sometimes in the 2/4 Oh Ray she o
you can't get to top and bottoms of
those that ballroom goes up for 10
storeys when it gets translated to this
one 9o ratio for IMAX which means you
see more of the top and the bottom we
never blew up shots
it's just revealing more of what was
already there it was an eye-opener I
have to say really it was it was like
more beauty in the piece look at what if
she is the one the one who break the
spell what the remarkable things is it's
not just the the scale of the sets but
also the movie has a big scope it has a
big ensemble you know there are dozens
of villagers in all of those scenes and
what I was really struck by was how much
more you can watch in an image you know
because it is so big and how many things
you notice there happening just sort of
a little bit in the background
especially in scenes where we hold on
shots for a long time it all came to
life it's the immersive quality right it
is that thing of being surrounded by the
movie and I think it's it's especially
appropriate for a music piece to meet
you part of the pleasure of watching a
musical is that it's communal experience
and somehow that became enhanced by
seeing it in this very immersive format
I was turning into the like who's there
you know like sounds that were coming
from here that that we'd mixed obviously
but still it I hadn't heard it in quite
this this nuance the way we recorded
this soundtracks of Abbey Road in London
not only the songs but the music Hughes
had a hundred piece Orchestra so to hear
it in an IMAX theatre you really get all
the detail that's the thing that's so
extraordinary you know that little bit
where the woodwinds take over suddenly
it just emerges just that extra bit
better because of this sound system it's
very hard to be able to see your movie
in a different way when you've seen it
over and over again so many times you
know but today today felt like seeing a
crash it made me feel like I was back on
the sets
[Music]
you